i come from a family that loved theater
and i love the mistakes i love the
messiness i love the seams
but i've always been afraid if i ever
did theater and i made a mistake or i
messed up what would happen have you
ever had an experience in the theater
like that and if so what did you do what
would you i don't even know where to
start right i mean essentially 25 years
in london and here
i mean
i've been set fire to in mid-air on
wires in andrew lloyd webber's the
wizard of oz that we did at the london
palladium
i i had a like a finger flash fire that
that would launch at the scarecrow as
you do down on the deck and set fire to
him he'd set off something but my
costume was completely black inky
feathers
and
the finger flash didn't go oh boy indeed
and i moved my hand back onto the
broomstick and my whole
dress went on fire what did you do i
went
mid-air and how funny is this at that
that very day my beloved friend clay
aiken was in the audience watching me
and was like
okay hold on broomstick
witch
don't get me started you are in
the new hocus pocus
[Applause]
this movie is so meaningful and
important to so many people sam
richardson was here the other day sam
richardson who is in ted lasso as well
that's right oh my god and so i grilled
him about it oh my gosh
is it like i would have paid them for
the privilege but don't tell them that
so i arrived for my costume fitting in
rhode island
and the second ad was like um the ladies
would love to meet you and i was like
the
the the
the ladies the witchy ladies and he was
like yeah they're just finishing up on
the scene but if you'd like to come to
set and i was like
yes please
and got driven there and they came off
set and there were dame bett kathy and
sjp sitting there
having their lunch
in a little box like we all do on set
in their costumes
so smoke
and i said i i just wanted to quickly
come and and say hello and and and and
bet
bet
was just like come come and sit and i
was like no no no you're having you're
having your time i get it i know it's
down time no no come and sit with us and
they were just
so delicious
and
bet was just like well played well
played for this year and i thought
i can't even believe you know i exist i
can't cope with it it was just insane
she's absolutely really something she's
my daughter is obsessed with the film
especially kathy najimi without though
i mean it's focused i've seen it
probably a hundred times i'm so excited
i'm so excited for this gift we all need
this like a ted lasso we're all gonna be
like
yes okay there's one other character
that i have to talk to you about is it
true
that you are
the nun
in game of thrones
who literally says the famous shane
yes
[Applause]
so don't
screw up otherwise i'll get you with my
bell
and
i've got my bell did you save it i've
got my bell they that's when you know
that you're dead
the show cause they're like here you are
here is your hero prop there we go i had
breakfast with miss heady this morning
no way yeah we oh we're in love with
wait a minute we're in love with each
other i don't know what i want more of a
picture hocus pocus too
and you and sjp kathy did me and the
divine miss m or
that you and lena hadley were literally
like
over scrambled eggs this morning
we are great pals
[Music]